so the title of your post was Pro to me
that Jesus was a Muslim right
yes so one of the things that I like to
usually talk with people is especially
whenever we are when we disagree on
different terms and topics of anything
it could be Health it could be whatever
whatever I always ask the individual if
they're sincere and so I ask you are you
generally sincere in your approach what
do you
think I think you have the intention to
be
about about
yourself I I want to always try to be
honest I think that if I'm ever in
dishonest it's because I have a bias or
I have a Prejudice and or I have a
predisposition of like no no I'm right I
have to be right and so it usually takes
me a time to reflect to so am I really
right or am I wrong and it requires me
to like really sit in silence meditate
or whatever in order to like try to find
what the truth is cuz EAS be wrong I
could easily be wrong in any belief that
I have right so this's what I would say
hold on there's an echo so when I when I
speak it sounds like we're gonna have to
oh I think it's the mic from the from
the because I'm on my phone right now so
I don't know if I can mute my mic when
you talk and that way we can like yeah
that that'll
work yeah that'll work um but is is
there a better do you have a computer
that you can that you can turn it on or
no
so I but I host their BN sorry so I do
but I host their BNB and so right now my
house is kind of packed I don't want to
involve them into our discussion okay
fair enough so yeah so when I talk you
just just mute and then we'll do it like
that but yeah so this what I'll say in
our conversation I think that our our
actions will show if we're sincere or
not um that's what Jesus says he says
you'll know them by their fruits so uh
if through this conversation we're you
know inconsistent or
disingenuous not being able to Humble
ourselves to each other and concede
points when a clear point is made or
clear there's it's okay to be to
disagree but if we're dishonest about
stuff that shows that you that we're not
sincere so that's that's how I take
it you know Pro to me becoming Muslim uh
just to give you a little bit of a
background so you have kind of like a
basis for my my progress
of how I got to this point I've been
Muslim for two years now I was raised as
a Catholic for almost 10 years 12 years
at that age and I became an atheist for
about another 10 years and then I became
Buddhist for about seven to eight years
at that point I read a book called The
Tibetan Book of the Dead where I found
out that Buddhist or a sect of Buddhism
believes in many gods and many layers of
heavens and things like that I was like
whoa this doesn't sound right I thought
Buddhism was agnostic or it was more
spiritual I was like uh something sound
there really weird and I I just
disconnected myself from it at that
point I became agnostic and through a
series of events I started learning
about Islam but prior to learning
Islam one of the things that I would say
prior and you know it's interesting
because Sam shamun even said a similar
quote to me but in different words where
I said okay well I've I've come to the
conclusion that Christianity is not the
truth that was the final religion that I
was studying and I said if Islam is not
the truth then nothing's the truth this
is a massive disillusion we're in we're
in a Sim relation this is a [__] lie
we've been lied to and nothing is real
that's it and so I began this process of
studying Islam Sam shimun on the other
hand ironically enough said something
similar but he's like if Christianity is
not the truth then nothing is real it's
like oh that's beautiful that's
interesting well sadly here we are
different points of views and so now I'm
talking to you the reason why I bring
that up is because I I did what I feel
is due diligence into studying what what
is true and what is not true and so I
know that you care mostly around me
proving to you why Jesus is a Muslim and
you already know the basic definition
that a Muslim is one who submits her
will to God if I ask you a question hey
did Jesus submit his will to God you
would say yes yes he did but where you
try to find the differences is that okay
well is God called the father is God
called Elohim or Adonai or Hashem or
whatever whatever all these Old
Testament terms or new testament terms
and you're like okay well by definition
he's not a father he's so he's not your
God so he's not Allah and so you Tred to
find that to disconect between the two
of them and I I understand your
reasoning I just think it's not truth
say that again why why do I think
that and you're able to cut me off if
you want at any given moment to like
explain yourself you're giving me a
break I'm sorry you're giving me a break
I'm listening okay
so why is think when it says Muslims
only why is it not
truthful okay so if I come to now said
hey know forgive me for this example on
camera what not but if I come to you hey
Avery I'm God and you'll be like what no
you're not no no no ay trust me I'm God
I'm I'm Jesus incarnate you're like no
the [__] you're not get out of
here yeah yeah I I'll aim to reduce my
language that's one of the things that
I've been working on but anyways
um if I say these things to you you'll
be like no that's not true you'd have to
be like prove yourself
and if I prove myself through Miracles
and wonders and prophecies and divine
information that no one could have known
then you'd be like H what is going on
here but clearly that's not going to be
the case because I'm not God now anybody
can have the name Jesus in their name
that doesn't mean that they're Jesus is
the Messiah so what identifies Jesus as
the Messiah it's not his name it's his
attributes correct it's his capabilities
it's his connections with God is his
divinity in your case or in my case it's
his prophethood the fact that he has
such a divine connection with God how is
what I'm saying not truthful so when I
say that's not truthful is because how
do we then Define God himself so you
already know what Allah means it's the
same thing as Elohim ala Adonai it's
it's Allah is not a name as ining as is
ibra uh you know Jesus or what else do
they call Jesus Emmanuel Sometimes some
Christians will call him Zar uh mesc
some other people will call
him uh the prince of peace the
Everlasting father whatever whatever
whatever how am I not truthful no no no
so this is this is the part where I'm
saying
so
if what defines God is his
attributes right he is omnicient he's
omnipotent he's omnipresent he's the
most loving he's the most just etc etc
etc ET all the 99 names that we
attribute or that we've learned through
Islam in this sense
then it's not that he needs to name the
Father the literal father in order for
it to apply Allah means the god he's not
just a God he's the God is he a father
I'm sorry is he a
father is he a father in a literal sense
no is he a father in any sense he's a
father in a in a parallel sense where
you and I what does a father do for you
and I they help they create a family
they are our creator he's your your
father is your creator my father is my
Creator but God he's our creator but
he's not our literal father and Muslims
don't call him our father because we
already saw what happened with
Christianity is
he I'm sorry is Allah a mother as well
no he's not a mother as well he's simply
our creator wait wait wait wait you just
said that Allah is a father in the sense
that you know he's creates the family
he's you know like a source right well a
mother is a caretaker of the family and
you know supports the family so isn't
doesn't All Care take for you and
support you so by that metric yes I
would agree but sense so what I I would
agree by what we're talking about right
now in the context that we're talking
between you and I personally yeah is he
a is he a mother in the sense that he's
a caretaker between not it's not a
definition that I would
islamically but if I'm talking to but if
I'm talking to you like I am right now
personally it would be like by
definition of what a mother does a
mother creates
us I only care islamically I only care
islamically so is Allah islamically can
you say that he is a mother
metaphorically in the way that he in the
sense that he's a caretaker and a
supporter can you islamically say that
and and so the the question is because
you say islamically you're now adding
the the placeholder of the question I
think I'm saying that correctly is no I
can't very good what about father
islamically is
Father islamically based on the terms
that we've been taught no it's not
something that we attribute all right so
this is where if this all comes in if
islamically Allah is not a father not
even metaphorically can you say that
he's a father Jesus says that God is his
father so
therefore he's not talking about the
same God that is in Islam right can we
talk about one thing is it possible
could you possibly see the possibility
that
Jesus called them the
father whether it's in a literal sense
or in a metaphysic or in a metaphorical
sense this this is what made me pause
with the previous guess
because whoever I talk to no matter how
many of you guys I talk to somehow some
way whenever I say any sense it seems
like it goes through one ear and out the
other when I say any sense that includes
whether it's literal
figurative allegorical
metaphorical
whatever is there any sense
islamically that Allah is a
father can I can I give you some context
as to why it's a good way to understand
why islamically we don't call him the
father no I don't I don't care context I
only okay no no okay so then let's use
that same reasoning of no I don't care
if I ask you right now and not I don't
want I don't want to get into like the
specifics of like challenging versus
because I know that's not your intention
of this Channel or this discussion but
if I ask you hey for real I need I need
a straight answer man I've been patient
I just I let I'll let you elaborate I'll
let you elaborate what you got to say
just give me a straight direct answer
please in Islam is Allah a father in any
sense the answer that you're looking for
is not the answer you're fine so no the
answer is no
he's a Creator he is a Creator by that
def definition you could call him a
father if you want but you're going to
be wrong because it's not a term that we
use thank you okay so islamically he's
not a father in any sense so if Jesus is
Calling God his father in any sense
whether but can we pause can we pause
for a second is a father a
Creator sure is every creator of father
I'm sorry I'm sorry is every Creator a
father no exactly so saying that uh he's
Creator and that that doesn't mean that
he's a
father
okay is every Creator a father in what
term are you talking about a Creator who
buil oh I'm losing them sorry when you
say is every creator of Father are you
talking about the specifically the title
of Creator like like a Creator who
creates a toy a Creator who builds a
house a Creator who builds a plan the
title
Creator okay so by that term no every
Creator is not a father but if a Creator
who brings life who creates the universe
who creates you and me who creates your
mother and your father by that
definition he is your father okay so all
right pause there so you're saying that
if he creates your life and all that
kind of stuff then he is your father so
then it sounds like you're you're going
back and forth you a moment ago you said
Allah is not a father in any sense
islamically he's not a father in any
sense but then now you just reasoned and
said well if whoever gives you life
right whoever creates you and gives life
is a source of your life that's who your
father that's your father so your your
reasoning is saying that yes that is a
father your creator is your father and
of your creator of your life is your
father but your religion says that no
Allah still not a father in any sense so
how does that
work so this is where I Ask of
sincerity which parts because I about 4
minutes ago I asked you can I tell you
the context behind this situation and
you're like no no no I don't care about
the context I just want to know if
islamically you can call him a father or
not so this is where I have to now give
you some context around the
religion but you don't care to hear that
so let me ask you when it comes to
sincerity if the factor it's like if I
ask you uh let me let me flip the allow
me to flip the allow me to tell tell me
the story about
Islam it's not it's not the story about
Islam but allow me to flip the tables
and allow me to flip the tables really
quick and
you Misha
respectfully I'm I'm asking very direct
questions now and I've answered them
have I not not not not not yet not yet
there's there's a lot of places where
we're still I don't know where you are
right now but one one moment you say
yeah no islamically he's not the father
in any sense and then a few moments
later you say that your creator of life
is your father so which is it is Allah a
father uh do you let's just be let's
just like end it right now let's just
make it clear right now yes in
Islam is Allah a father in any sense at
all it's not a term that is accepted
islamically that has been your my answer
from the beginning it is not a ter it is
not a term it is not a term it is not a
term that's used anywhere islamically so
is the answer no so the answer to your
question is no thank you all right let's
pause because this is important this is
important no but this is very important
as well which is why please pause
because we're wasting time so
islamically Allah is not a father at all
no sense no way no how got it so if
Jesus is saying that God is his father
is he believing and talking about the
same God that the Quran is describing
who says God is not the father in any
way shape or form
yeah based on the
limited par parameters that you're
setting the answer is always going to be
no thank you the answer is always going
to be no but now this is where I ask you
if you're being sincere or not and if
you want to hear me if you can handle
what I'm going to ask you because in the
same way that you're putting these
questions towards me and you're
narrowing my cap abilities to answer
you're not giving me freedom of the
ability to talk you're not matter of
fact I've given you so much freedom to
talk no no no giving you so much room to
talk and this is and this and this is
where you know when certain people come
up and and they like I've had guests
like you before Misha I have I've had
guests like you before
this I even let you hold on Misha I even
let you spend five minutes telling your
background story yes uninterrupted I let
you speak uninterrupted I've asked
direct questions and I've let
you not answer directly I've let you
talk uninterrupted so now that I'm
actually honing in on my questions that
are specific and direct and all it
requires are direct answers it doesn't
require elaboration even though I allow
it it only it requires simple direct
answers but you haven't allow you hav't
now you're saying I'm not letting you
speak this is tough for me man well can
you see the difference yeah I I see do
you see the
difference okay so you allowed me to
give my background you allowed me to
talk in the beginning you did then when
it comes to the specifics of the actual
matter the detail that matters I can't
get any words in you've allowed me you
gave you got more than enough words in
am Misha don't do that you let me speak
about the things that were irrelevant to
the discuss I let you speak I let you
speak on what on on your elaboration on
Allah being a father mother the
metaphorical senses that you're talking
I let you elaborate on all of that I let
you speak do not come here and this is
what like this is where it'll start to
get Negative here don't come here doing
this don't do that you've been able to
speak freely here I let you speak a lot
some people will say I let you speak too
much but that's how generous I I'm a
patient dude I let people talk so let's
not do this and pretend that you haven't
had a voice here so let's get straight
back to the point here so you said in
answering under the parameters with the
questions being direct Jesus when he
says God is his father he's not talking
about the same God that's described in
Islam
IE but you no you you this is what you
said yes so then you don't disagree
that's what you said do you can I but
all right may I answer go ahead you
Islam Islam came after Jesus correct
obviously
mhm Prophet Muhammad's role as we've
understood so far I'm assuming you've
understood this as well or at least what
you've been told whether you accept it
or not was not only to bring back the
people of Arabia The Descendants ofish
B sorry
sorry no I lost
them yeah man getting people people
every time they get hooked on their own
words now now now now I ain't let them
speak come on man let's not do that man
you back what's up yeah sorry about that
it's uh I had an go
off
okay the role the the the duty of the
Prophet was to bring back the
descendants of ishmail back to back to
monotheism because at the time you
already knew that the were worshipping
Idols so he corrected he corrected a lot
of wrongful beliefs and mistakes in the
past correct a lot of errors that were
misrepresented whether in their
civilization or among the older books as
you've talked in your previous
scriptures how
uh how can I say
this the
association of divinity to Jesus was one
of the things that needed to be
corrected the associate a of the
crucifixion needed to be corrected and
we have evidence for this where we have
clear evidence that the Bible has been
corrupted in many ways you see what
you're doing do you see what you're
doing I've given you free reign to speak
and you haven't touched on what I said
you started telling me the story of
Islam and why Muhammad came you haven't
touched what I said do you think that
I'm not trying to answer that question
maybe maybe not by look like I said in
the beginning by your fruits I know them
yes so by your actions it sounds it seem
seems like you're avoiding what I just
said you said that you was about to
touch on it directly and you haven't yet
and you've been speaking for over a
minute now you're you're right so please
touch on what I said okay or what you
said that Jesus saying that God is his
father Yes is means that he's not
talking about the same God that's
described in Islam who's not a father in
any shape and form what do you have to
what is your response or elaboration
with that so Prophet Muhammad corrected
these beliefs of the past so he
corrected Jesus
correct okay so Muhammad Muhammad came
Jesus in the past had a incorrect view
of God and Muhammad came and corrected
Jesus's view of God is that
right can we yes I'm gonna say yes but
can I say something can I can I ask you
a question to see what you say to this
hold on just
go ahead go ahead and ask you a question
I just gota okay note that down in
sorry just waiting for you once you're
ready one what's today today's the 20
22nd we go all right one
22 25
Muhammad
corrected the
beliefs of
Jesus Jesus had the incorrect belief
about God being his father all right go
ahead
answer look the reason why I make this
statement and even though I could be
wrong in it easily could be wrong in it
this is why at the beginning I preface
this this statement with hey if I'm
wrong please correct me whether it's
whether it's another Muslim whether it's
a scholar whatever it may be the reason
why I said that statement in the way
that I did is because you and I both
have evidence that the Bible has been
altered and changed we have evidence
that verses have been put into the Bible
I disagree but what does that have to do
with what we said because that's a
different subject okay so let's a very
easy example that you know two very easy
examples that you already know about
what 1 John 5:7 and Hebrews one Misha
see this is where um I this is where I'm
I'm cutting in and I have to bring you
back to the focus of the the
conversation because you're shuffling
over now to Bible corruption instead of
dealing with the issue at hand on Jesus
Jesus having the incorrect belief in God
as his father you said that Muhammad
corrected Jesus's belief that God was
his father go ahead and expound on that
so Jesus had the wrong belief as the
Messiah and prophet of God okay perfect
so I have to find ways to try and
introduces to you in a way that doesn't
divert from your topic
so how do you know you yourself that
what Jesus said that was written in the
Bible is what Jesus
said because it's early attestation
independent sources and your Quran says
it okay but no don't don't use the Quran
because even though the Quran you're
Muslim even though the Quran attests the
existence of the in and the Torah those
are not the only things that it says it
also tells you that use the Quran as a
as a as a standard amongst any
disagreements and it also tells us that
the the old that the old Torah and theel
were both corrupted no no it
doesn't it say it says just
chapter chapter five yeah we could look
look let me show you something please I
don't know if you can put it on for us
yeah I'm G show you something I want you
to see what the Quran tells me to
do I might actually have to get my
tablet as well because very good all
right can you see the screen let me see
really quick uh can you move your camera
let the people judge by what Allah has
revealed therein and whosoever does not
judge by okay so perfect so let the
people of
Theo judge by what Allah has revealed
therein and whosoever does not judge by
what Allah has revealed to them such
people are fakun so can you do me a
favor and according to this verse what
am I supposed to judge by as a as a
person of the Gospel so one of the
things that yes so one of the things
that a lot of Christians have noticed do
is that they'll take one specific verse
to supplement to support their argument
we need to add more verses in the same
way that you want us to read the context
of the whenever we're bringing something
up we need you to also see the context
so can you the according according to
this verse what no no don't limit it
there please please exp not I promise
you I'm I I will definitely go to the
next verse I love the next verse okay so
it says it says judge between what Allah
has revealed for them in the in the
that's it so so what am I supposed to
judge by as a person of the Gospel what
am I supposed to use as my judge you
judge between what you have before you
with what with theil with the Bible with
the yes so if something goes against the
gospel with the Bible then I judge that
thing is false right hey but but but
Avery what you know what you're doing
brother okay read all we do is read over
here man okay let's let's let's continue
reading then can you please thr up a
little bit yes uh verse 48 and we have
sent down and we have sent down to you
Muhammad this book The Quran so now
we're talking about the Quran in truth
the Quran is speaking the truth so that
means that the verse before is
acknowledging that Theo exists so and
not just that it exists but it's used
it's authoritative and supposed to be
used as it's authoritative exactly this
confirms the scripture that came before
them before it being the Quran and
trustworthy over it old scriptures so
but wait that's the that's the key part
right there um we have revealed we have
sent un to you Muhammad the Quran this
book confirming the scripture that came
before it over it so judge between them
what Allah has revealed and follow not
their vain desires the virginal way so
this specifically is telling you to use
the Quran who God is telling us all of
us what do you mean okay God is telling
Muhammad to use this Quran in
truth okay conf to conf not to to
confirm the scripture before the
Quran and to use this book the Quran
over these old
scriptures it doesn't say use it over
the Scriptures it said do you not see
where it says over it what what what is
over it it says that it's
a over it use this talking let's we have
to read the the we have to use the
subject that it's talking about it's Ed
the book in truth to confirm the
scripture that came before it no it
doesn't say use it to confirm it it says
that it that the Quran already confirms
it it says the Quran came down
confirming the scripture that came
before it
and yes right which means guarding
witness and what is what is muhamed the
Quran right yeah the Quran okay and
you're gonna and you're gonna
use so judge between them by what Allah
has revealed and follow not their vain
desires who because books don't have
desires so what does he the the
Christians and everybody else very good
very good we agree so use he's using the
Quran to judge between them and to not
follow their vain desires because they
could be Hypocrites they could be lying
and stuff like that diverging away from
the truth that has come to you now watch
this to each among you now he's talking
all about all groups the Jews the
Christians and the Muslims because
that's the previous verses he addresses
the Jews he addresses the Christians
addresses the Muslims so now says to
each among you we have prescribed a law
in a clear way what's the law for the
Jews this the Torah the law for the
Christians is the Ino can you can you
give me a
second what Surah and verses this so I
can look it up my really quick chapter 5
verse
48 thanks give me a
second is there a reason you use this
one and not quran.com
um it's easier for me to navigate
there's no problem with k.com
though do you want me to go to
the yeah chapter 5 vers
40 oh Afghan is
here hey Afghan come join on
YouTube now
can you put you know one of the reasons
why I asked you to bring this up I ask
you to go because this this you you're
familiar that not I don't speak Arabic
by the way but you and I know that this
book was revealed in Arabic and then
it's been translated in many languages I
to different to different nations on top
of that in many variations of English
and different English translations have
had different uh ways to try and express
what it is that it's saying in Arabic
and so I'm asking I don't know who Hil
and is I wanted to know two Scholars or
two do you think we can do you think
that we can use sah International which
is one of the more common most widely
reputable ones in terms of its
translation it gets a lot wrong actually
that's why I don't use sah International
a lot I would maybe that's a different
discussion for a different day in
regards to what it uses wrong but if we
can jump to that website and you can see
what the difference is in terms of trans
I know know the difference I know like
in in the S International it'll say
something like uh uh does it say supreme
authority instead no that's that's the
must that's the Mustafa Kabab or
something like that that's a that's a
different the clear Quran but I want to
go to sah International because it's
it's it's also a different one than what
you have over here wa does it help like
what's what's the point it well it won't
help your case if that's what you if
that's what you're looking
for you you're asking me to bring up
something that helps my case no I'm
asking you to bring up the clear the sah
International trans how would that help
us because it says something slightly
different than what it says here I know
how will it
help okay because okay I'll let me read
it to you from my own self over here
yeah I already the reason why it'll help
the reason why it'll help is because it
says that the book the Quran in truth it
confirms that which preceded it over the
scripture and as a Criterion over it
yeah the word it's a m translation there
the the word is not Criterion Criterion
in the Arabic is foran this is miman
miman is not criterian it's guardian or
witness over it that's why that's why I
didn't this is why I didn't use I don't
I don't like sa International because it
does that a lot it it corrupts the text
a
lot like look if I if I show you the
roots go back wait wait wait stay where
you are for a second so I can read the
mam part I'mma show you the Arabic I'm G
show you the Arabic yeah yeah look um
right here W mahim is a guardian not
criter and so when it's a guardian it's
a guardian of the previous
scripture okay so if it's if if the
Quran is a guardian over the previous
scripture yep and it's the book in truth
and you're using it to support your
argument that it's trying to support the
validity of the past when it's telling
you that hey this thing is filled with
truth this Quran is filled in truth it's
trustworthy and it's a witness a witness
it says the same thing about the
previous scriptures that they're
trustworthy and that they're true that
they have guidance and light in them yes
but
we're it's if anything contradicts the
Quran then clearly if the book Quran
cannot be in truth and and
trustworthy so if the Quran is a
guardian that's not true brother look
let me show you something wait no no no
what do you mean oh okay show me show me
I'm about to show you that it's actually
if it contradicts the previous
scriptures then the Quran is
false look um chapter 10 verse
94 so it says this is Chap so this is
chapter 10 verse 94 s unas
verse
94 it says so if you are in doubt
concerning that which we have revealed
to you all right um I I skipped the
brackets because that's not part of the
the understand I understand yeah um then
ask those who are reading the book
before
you verily the truth has come to you
from your lord so be not of those who
doubt so this says this talk Allah
talking to Muhammad and says Muhammad if
you're doubting what we revealed to you
then go ask the people who've been
reading the scripture before you truly
the this the truth has come to you from
your lord so don't doubt wait but can
hold up because this is why skipping the
brackets in this context because I know
that if we read the previous verses it's
going to explain what this bracket is
saying and it's telling you in this if
you're in doubt concerning that which we
have revealed to you which is that your
name is written both in the Torah and in
the gospel then ask those who are
reading the book so this is not under
the context of verifying the the
entirety of the Bible and the Torah but
it's telling you that your name is there
and yeah let me let let me disagree
because it is but it's not just talking
about Muhammad's name but also the
stories of the previous prophets that
the that the Quran is talking about
before this verse correct it's
Muhammad's prophethood I got to mute you
it's Muhammad's prophethood and it's the
the stories of the previous prophets
like Moses the uh Israelites um pharaoh
and all that kind of stuff right The
Exodus so it says if you're doubting
what we revealed to you how does he
verify what what what does Allah tell
him to do to verify what has been
revealed to him he has to go check the
previous scriptures
right so right so with that being said
oh go
ahead but you are also aware and they
brought up to you that there's about
four or five other verses to talk about
the many different types of Corruptions
that happened between those of the old
book who exchanged it for money and
things like that you also know that
there's a history no no no hold up let
me let me finish making the point and
then I'll I'll hear I'll hear your
disagreement there are multiple verses
which sadly I don't have off the top of
my head I would need your help in
searching them or I would need a laptop
but
or you if you can give me five minutes I
can be back and whatever anyways um
there's many verses that remind us that
the old scriptures have been corrupted
it's not
only that they have been changed that
they exchanged the truth for saying that
this is what is from God they've told he
tells us multiple times and I can that's
why I rather bring them up to you one by
one I have let me Grant this to you
Misha let me grant you that according to
the Quran the previous scriptures have
been distorted and changed
yes so why in the world would Allah tell
Muhammad if he's doubting the Quran and
what was what's revealed specifically
why would
Allah try who's supposed to be you know
lead you into guidance and light why
would he lead Muhammad to a distorted
book to verify his doubts of the Quran
and that's where we connected with the
first verse that we just brought up
where it says use this use this Quran as
a guarden over these books that's not
what it says no no no you don't don't
please please I beg you do not look at
verses individually see them as a
whole I'm begging you to look at the
verse period please look at the verse at
in the first place you're not even
looking at the verse okay tell me if I'm
getting you correct okay I'm gonna
repeat what you said in a way that you
understand it and then hopefully move on
from there you are saying hey Muhammad
if you doubt the Quran that we have
revealed to you then refer to those
before you who are reading the Torah the
NG before you verily the truth has come
so he's telling Muhammad ask the
Christians and the Jews what we have
sent them to verify what I am sending to
you right now boom okay yeah boom so I
understand you so you can understand
that I'm being sincere and understanding
you do you agree with that that's what
the verse says of course but but please
it doesn't end there it doesn't end that
one that one verse that's why all the
verses matter no no no but don't shake
your head because you don't just because
you don't like what I'm gonna say you
like you're not deal the issue Misha
you're not dealing with the issue but
neither and can I say that you're not
doing it either okay if you're saying it
let's see who's not dealing with the
issue I just I just granted you your
position that the scriptures are
corrupted you just said and you agreed
with me that the verse tells Muhammad to
go verify his doubts by using the
previous scriptures of the Quran right
yes so why would Allah send Muhammad to
distorted scripture
to verify what the Quran says if the
Quran is the supreme authority and and
the guardian by which he's supposed to
judge with why telling him to use the
previous scriptures to judge and not the
Quran okay sorry I keep forgetting to
mute the mic um the reason is because
both the Bible and the Torah oh sorry
both the both the New Testament and the
Torah contain some
truth how will he know how will he know
thank you and that's the path towards
sincerity how do you know it's the truth
how would mhamad know that's the
question how would Muhammad know that
what which is true how would he so when
you use the Quran as a criteria and it's
a trustworth wait let me finish
okay Quan that's what you're not getting
Misha he's doubting the
Quran let me let please please please
first of all the context in which that
verse that says hey refer to the old
books it's referring to finding your
name in the Bible and the Torah that's
the context of that verse no it's not
it's to go it's in the brackets is it
not that's the brackets that's wrong how
do you okay so wait we we wanted to
ignore sah International because it was
a bad translation then we go to this
translation we I IGN I ignored the
brackets and only read what was of the
verse I understand but the
brackets the the brackets are giving
context to the previous verse no the
brackets are giving
interpretation but they're also giving
context of previous verses that you and
I are not now there's nothing in the
previous verses that says that
Muhammad's name is mentioned in the
previous scriptures dude let me say it
again there's nothing there's nothing in
chapter 10 from verse one to 93 that
says Muhammad's name is mentioned in the
scriptures the previous scriptures okay
I I can't do this for my phone because
I'm very limited right now so allow me
to hold on what you're saying and you
ask me why is he referring to the Old
Testament and the and the and the Torah
when he's doubting this I am telling you
that first this is not the only verse
that was revealed there's verses that
have been revealed that the Quran I mean
that the Torah and the Bible have been
corrupted one keep this in mind
two it not only has it been corrupted
but he gives us evid no sorry please
give me a second because your reaction
right now is actually uh it's affecting
my guard give me a second give me a
second I lost my train of
thought your reaction right now is like
ah [__] man like I'm trying to be
sincere I'm hoping we can actually have
a Ser a genuine discussion but I know
that you're trying to push for a point
of like look why would you ever refer to
something that which you cannot trust
that is corrupted I get your point I
think I think we're getting
I I think we're getting to a point where
um you know we we just won't get
anywhere because but that's why I'm
trying to ask you a question I want I I
really need your sincere at least in
this aspect if you can really answer me
this question it's over it's over
because you can't deal with what I'm
saying you can't engage with what I'm
saying but didn't I answer your
questions every time no you're not
you're no you didn't you didn't the
question is still here why is the Quran
you know I'll give you this last chance
if you can't deal with this bro we're
done we got to call it a day sorry why
in the world in Allah's Paradise would
he tell Muhammad if Muhammed already has
the Criterion he already has the book
and Truth why would he tell him to go to
a book that's distorted to go to a book
that's corrupted and changed to verify
the doubts that he might have in the
Criterion
because there's evidence of Truth in
there okay let's do it this way did that
not make sense to you let's do it this
way let's say let's say no it doesn't
let me let me let's let me do it this
way um if if you're telling me a story
right Misha you're telling me a story or
you know what no you're telling uh let's
say you're telling someone you live with
a story let's say your wife you're
telling your wife a story um of of our
conversation right how you met me this
conversation today of how you come in my
stream and um you tell your wife you
say um if you don't believe me if you're
doubting what I'm saying then go ask
Avery who was running the live
stream so you're telling her in order to
verify what you're saying to go ask me
the host of the live stream and I will
be able to cooperate what you said right
right now if she comes to me and she
says Hey Avery did Misha ever come to
your stream and I say yeah Misha did he
was on the stream we we spoke for like
30 minutes then she would know that what
you said you were telling the truth
right okay now let's say the opposite
happens she comes to me and she says Hey
Avery did Misha ever come to your stream
and I said who's Misha no nobody named
Misha ever came to my stream then she
would know that you told a lie
right okay so what is the criteria on
whether or not you told the truth is it
you in your own word or is it me is it
my cooperation of what you said what's
the Criterion here go ahead you can you
can
answer I I love me beautiful can we pull
up that same verse that we're talking
about right now
I'm and I'm going to ask you to go to
the verse right before
it and indeed we settled the children of
Israel in an honorable dwelling place
and provided them with good things that
they differed not until the knowledge
came to them verely a law will judge
between them on the day
of thanks thanks for coming man